so now when I hire people and then they
come from schools they come out of UCLA
if they come out of Harvard if they come
out of a Berkeley it's obvious you know
where Berkeley is that if they come a
lot of these schools even Yale you're
you're the reason why a Sanders was able
to get as much traction as he did is a
byproduct of the last 30 or socialism's
getting a lot of education and school
and a lot of socialists are able to pass
their agenda to kids and kids are
thinking about it you're seeing that
it's not like I'm the first person
that's telling you this so let's stop
Patrick I don't agree with that you
don't agree with the fact that the
spirit of socialism is and universities
today absolutely let me explain to you
what I mean first of all I don't like
Hillary Clinton I wouldn't I would not
have bowed down to Hillary Clinton then
I wouldn't do it now she is for me the
other side of the same coin that mr.
Trump is on the other side of and I
don't want that point neither the one
side nor the other a socialist
perspective as far as I understand it
has a you know finds the distinction
between those two of them minimal it's
not zero but it's minimal and an excited
supporter of either of them you would
not find me to be now on the question of
Bernie and the interest in quote-unquote
socialism I go all over the country
I really do I interact with these people
all the time and here's what I can tell
you which may come for you may upset you
I don't know they are not pro socialist
whatever they say on their polls what
they are is bitter and angry that what
they took to be the promise of
capitalism isn't available to them they
are loaded up with debt going through
their college the quality and quantity
of jobs they can get with their BA is
worse than it's ever been
they were led to expect by their parents
by their minister by the community they
grew up in a set of opportunities that
are fast disappearing and they know it
from talking
to one another they feel to be blunt
betrayed by capitalism that's what
they're saying when they say well what's
wrong with socialism because it really
isn't that socialism has captured them
or that they even know much about it
it's just it's their way of giving the
things I agree with the capitalism I
actually agree with what you just said
and I totally get what you just said but
this is the part I agree with let me
explain so you said there it's not that
you know how nowadays they say people
don't vote for somebody they vote
against somebody you've heard this
before your entire yes yes so they're
bitter at capitalism okay so now go to
capitalism so now the next question I'll
be asking you is what what is the
definition of capitalism to you because
you went straight from capitalism to
college debt that college debt is not
capitalism college debt is controlled by
the government being able to push every
debt through them to find a way to make
more money College could be one-sixth
double costs what it is today when you
got a Harvard University sitting on
forty billion dollars of endowment and
they took a eight point five five
million dollar check from the government
just two months ago because of
coronavirus and they're sitting on 40
billion colleges are more expensive
because of government if you look at
that a debt is higher due to government
they don't have to lower the interest
rates the way they are to what where it
is today giving money away constantly to
bail people out that's the government's
ties that's not a capitalistic system a
true capitalistic system is not the
involvement of the government trying to
bail on somebody's too big to fail
companies so I'm not coming from a place
of let's go bailout another of these big
companies and let's not prevent it from
going out of business if they screw up
they should go out of business but
that's not capitalism that is a button
I'll finish up and I'll give you a turn
it over to you that is a interpretation
of these teachers who have jobs making
49 grandeur 262 thousand a year
eighty-two thousand year if they're
professors or maybe higher-ups private
school most teachers you know don't make
a lot of money they make thirty six
thousand forty thousand I don't see
teachers getting up saying capitalism's
awesome guys I don't see that I see
teachers
for sixteen years saying how bad
capitalism is and how bad rich people
are because they're not the happiest
people in the world sixteen years later
these 22 your kids are like do these
rich people suck and capital some sucks
who's against rich people Bernie
I'll freaking vote for this guy that's
how I see the process and taking place
[Music]